diy sunscreens like this are not a good  idea even if you mix in the same amount  of zinc oxide as a store-bought  sunscreen the sun protection you get  isn't just about the percentage of zinc  oxide but also how it's distributed in  the sunscreen and how that applies on  your skin even with 20 of the right type  of zinc oxide mixed with industrial  equipment that can make the zinc oxide  spread out in the product evenly  sunscreen formulators still get low spf  sometimes because the base isn't keeping  the zinc oxide spread out when you apply  it on your skin this clumping issue is  even worse with uncoated zinc oxide  which is the type that most diy recipes  use synthetic coatings are usually used  in proper zinc oxide sunscreens to keep  it spread out a lot more evenly so if  professional sunscreen formulators can't  do it consistently with all of this  extra help the chance of you getting it  right consistently in your kitchen  without any of this is  not great